I don't care you have had the same pair
of clothes your whole life be sure a lot
of you go to that back you got a shot
I choose optimism look I'm really
excited to be here you know obviously
with a smaller group I hope we can do a
bunch of Q&A I'll try to give you a
little context about what I want to talk
about and then take it from there I
think the the thing that has allowed me
to travel a lot and speak is that the
only thing I ever think about when I
talk is the audience you know how do you
create context that matters for the
people in the room I speak at events
that have people that run fortune 500
companies that do 50 billion dollars a
year and I speak to athletes and
emerging hip-hop artists and kids and I
run the gamut to be very frank with you
I'm only interested in talking about
something that's gonna bring value to
the 2030 people in this room and so the
things I'm gonna spit right now are the
things that I think makes sense based on
the very little I know about the people
in the room I was born in in the Soviet
Union in Belarus when I came to America
I was three years old I lived in a
studio apartment in Queens with eight
family members I didn't see my dad until
I was 14 years old because he worked
every minute and we didn't have lunch
and we grinded I think the thing that
excites me is you know I so appreciate
the nice intro but me investing in
Facebook and Twitter Newberg is not
what's on the mind set in this room buts
in the mindset of this room for me and
I'll let you ask your own questions I'm
not interested in judging or assuming
but for me what I'm most excited about
is that there's never been a time ever
where there's been so much opportunity
in the world and I don't think people
realize it because I think people don't
realize what's gone on with this
internet thing you're most people in
here a bunch of youngsters you've never
known the world pre-internet when I was
18 I still never seen the
in my life cuz I'm old and that's how I
came up and so for me this internet
thing is changing everything everything
that's happening in our society
everybody in this room including myself
is grossly under estimating the Internet
and for me the only passion I have is
how quickly can you have it consistently
because the second you realize what the
[ __ ] that thing is and you understand
what it means it eliminates everything
that's ever happened before every single
thing that's happened before becomes
irrelevant when you have that
opportunity because the reality is it's
just game-changing I'll give you a quick
story this uh this Saturday I had dinner
with my parents which was awesome
because I'm hustling so hard that you
know I don't get to see them as much as
I want and we had dinner and we're
bouncing and the waitress ran after me
and grabbed me it was like hey I just
want to thank you and I was like sure
she's like my fiancee didn't have a job
fifteen months ago and then he saw a
video you posted on YouTube in the last
15 months he made 1.5 million dollars
off of a thousand dollar investment in
buying stuff in China and selling it on
the Amazon and yeah that's real good and
and it really hit me so hard
because I was thinking to myself my god
between YouTube and instagramming these
things free information right guy had a
thousand dollars and he was it I mean if
he made fifteen thousand dollars that
would have seemed crazy if he made a
hundred fifty thousand dollars that
would have been all time would have
changed his life to go from not having a
job and having a thousand dollars to
making 1.5 million dollars in a year
it's just batshit crazy and was not
possible when I was growing up took
decades to mask that kind of wealth the
opportunity is is ridiculous what's up
everybody
how you doing thanks for coming through
so look for me it's real simple right I
was kind of laughing if you do have
Instagram and you went to my Instagram
account and he looked at my post eight
post or nine posts ago you'd see
something interesting I'm sure for a lot
of people in this room
you're uh you're pounded the value of
education school right got brought up
like three or four times I was a DNF
student I I sucked at school like I got
like I actually was so bad at school
that I had my my admin my my system
reach out to my high school and get a
copy of my report card so I could put on
Instagram the other day because people
are confused what success looks like or
how you get there it doesn't mean that
you should look at me and not do school
it means that you need to look at
yourself and figure out who you are what
are you good at what do you like how
you're gonna get to the place that you
want to get to and so for me I got four
A's in high school in my entire career
all in gym right look I got a D in
yearbook you know and so to me there's
just a thousand paths out there and so
for me I'm curious about one by one one
by one for the thirty people in this
room where is their mindset where are
they at who are they listening to what
are they judging their self-worth and
their ambition based on what how are
they counting the points because when
you're a youngster you're looking at all
sorts of different things
you're being affected by all sorts of
different voices and for me the only
thing that worked even though I was
getting D's and F's and all my friends
parents told me I was a loser even all
my teachers told me I wasn't gonna be
anything even though I didn't have stuff
even though I was you know I just was in
my own head I knew exactly who I was but
the thing that I was willing to do was I
was willing to work and the thing that
my parents taught me was not to dwell
not to cry about it
I didn't have [ __ ] when I rolled up on
my mom when I was nine when Nintendo was
popping cuz I when it first broke I was
at mom I need a Nintendo she's like good
go get it
and so I shoveled snow and I ripped
people's flowers out of their yard and
sold it back to them
yeah which is my favorite one there's so
many amazing people but ultimately the
world doesn't care everybody grows up
with [ __ ] right it's crazy for me to be
in this room because 48 hours ago I had
dinner with somebody was crying for four
hours over dinner with me because he has
ten million dollars in his trust fund
and he thinks that he'll never be able
to be his own man
cuz everybody's gonna say that his
grandfather put him on and his life is
ruined cuz he has ten million dollars in
the bank every person in here that just
heard that said get the [ __ ] out of here
right right but guess what that's his
[ __ ] thing that's in his head that's
his circumstance and to be straight to
the face with you I actually think that
that is scarier because there's nothing
he can never do to get away from the
fact that he was put on like that and
everybody will judge him for life I
genuinely believe genuinely believe this
I don't know your circumstances and I'm
gonna make but I'm telling you once you
get this if you don't have it your
emotion the game has started
period give me $5 and a cell phone that
has internet and I'm off to the races
I'll go to a dollar store I'll buy five
things I'll put them on eBay and I'll
have $13 later
and on and on and on and so I'm a place
where I'm not here to rah-rah you or
make myself feel good that I'm doing
something nice I'm doing something nice
every day I'm here because if I can get
one of you to realize how ridiculous it
is how your grandparents if they were in
a situation it would have taken them
decades but for you if you really put in
the work to educate yourself educating
is in school educating is a whole
different game and so for me I'm here
because I'm giving back to the one thing
that got me to the place that I'm at and
that's hustle work and everybody has
that at bat if they want it and there's
a million ways to do it and the fact
that you can do it now at scale with
this blows my face
changes everything
and if you don't have that you need to
figure out how to get to that if you can
get to that then the whole world is open
to you you need to really quantify how
special this time is it's real and
you've got two choices every day of your
life you're either optimistic or you're
pessimistic you're either seeing what's
good or you're seeing what's bad my
whole life even when I was like in a
very different place I would always just
say seven billion people out seven seven
seven point seven billion people where
do I rank for all the [ __ ] that I got
for all the negativity where do I rank
am I better than the person that's
terminally ill that has a lot of money
that's gonna die a month yeah am I
better than somebody who's living in a
cage in parts of the world that we don't
even want to look at yeah and so to me
this is a mindset game and it's real
hard it's real hard to penetrate your
mindset right now because where you're
at in the game it's early might as one
ambition in here right now is to get one
person in this room to realize how much
offense and how early it is in your game
I put out a lot of content and my
favorite piece of content right now
because I get so many emails from 20 and
30 year olds who are upset concerned
worried and I always tell them like it's
not even half time it's not even half
time you're worried about losing or it's
not going your way and your game hasn't
even started if you want if this
organization can really do some good
they need to start sending you to
retirement homes and you need to start
spending time with people that are 80 90
100 years old
you need context it's really hard for me
to worry about anybody in this room when
you're in the first inning when you're
in the first quarter what happens in the
first twenty years of your life means
[ __ ] means nothing and to be very honest
you don't want to hear this from me but
I'm just gonna tell you cuz it's the
[ __ ] truth I think your adversity is
your [ __ ] gift straight up because
what you don't realize is happening
right now in the world is the Internet
is making everything equal and the chip
on the shoulder that's
forming on you right now the fact that
you're not entitled and you're not
[ __ ] soft and you can appreciate [ __ ]
that's gonna play out in your 20s 30s
and 40s you don't see it now but you're
gonna look at it the same way I did when
I was 9 and my mom said go [ __ ] yourself
by your own Nintendo I hated life now
it's the best [ __ ] that ever happened to
me when I was 13 and I had to work every
weekend and make 2 bucks an hour bagging
ice for 15 hours a day and all my
friends were partying and hooking up and
having fun and going to parties and [ __ ]
I hated it now it's the best [ __ ] that
ever happened to me so well everybody
was looking down at me back then I was
looking inside my own head and honestly
every time anybody looked down at me I
registered that [ __ ] and put it in the
column and that [ __ ] [ __ ] became my
fuel and so I think you're lucky and I
know you don't but just remember in 20
or 30 years this talk because I think
you might agree if you're willing to put
in the work and bunch of you were just
gonna dwell on it
that's facts that's just real life just
math a bunch of people gonna be like yo
I got dealt a [ __ ] hand [ __ ] this
life sucks the game sucks which is cool
you do you actually I'll be really frank
with you I don't give a [ __ ] I mean it
what it's the truth I can't control that
but I'm real curious about the people
that are putting this energy in the
right pocket in the right place building
that ship building that ship because if
this was 1986 with no internet you would
have been at a tough spot we were taking
a long long long time but this internet
thing doesn't care who you are that's
real so biggest piece of advice I could
give you the quickest way you could
figure out how to sell [ __ ] that would
really teach you a lot no matter who you
are in this room if you can learn how to
buy something or get something get it
how you have to get it and learn how to
sell it I would highly recommend it
the quickest way you can figure out how
to sell on Facebook marketplace in eBay
and Amazon if you can learn that game if
you've got aspirations if you want to
win it's a it's a land grab out there
it's a lane grab out there you know
there's a piece of content I've been
making an insert of in YouTube for about
a year year and a half about going to
try to set the mood I got you um about
going to thrift stores and dollar stores
and flipping if it's crazy so uh I'll
tell you how it happened actually about
a year and a half ago about a year and
about a year and a half ago I was on
Breakfast Club and I was going real well
Charlotte mean was real nice and an
envied kind of ran up I mean it was like
you know this motivational [ __ ] is
[ __ ] give us something tangible and
so like I'm like you know you know the
radio you're live you got a few minutes
and like [ __ ] what I'm gonna say and I
went back to what got me to where I am
today just buying and selling stuff for
me it was baseball cards because that's
what people wanted back in the day for a
lot of other people there's so much to
do to me it's real interesting alright I
was think about this the other day I was
go to the airport I saw this huge line
outside a sneaker shop and it was like
5:15 in the morning and I looked at
everybody I was like yeah those are my
people right because they're just like
they're just hungry just willing to
stand outside a sneaker store at 4:30 in
the morning and cold cuz they know
they're gonna flip those ez-zor Supremes
and make a couple hundred bucks and I
think that person has the advantage in
the world going forward because what
stopped everybody from winning before
was there were people stopping people
but now the Internet is the actual
middle not some old rich person or
anything over the house there's nobody
else that gets the judge so if you and
especially for you because once you get
the phone once you play this stuff is
native to you you understand it
and so I highly recommend you figure out
how to use it to get yours because it's
there it's really really there and if
it's selling cool because I think that's
the easiest one to be honest with you
start with $10 but if it's not selling
that it's about making content and
getting people to pay attention to you
maybe you can sing maybe you can dance
maybe you can dunk I don't know what
you're
- but sitting and worrying about it and
sitting around and contemplating it
isn't gonna get it done and the only
people that are willing to listen to you
to complain are other people that are
losing and that's facts so I highly
recommend you get your head and do a
place where you just go on the offense
straight offense because you have the
options you have the options and so I
think it's the greatest time to be alive
the Internet is still new there's still
so much to take you could absolutely
grab it it could be yours it's just
about going into a different place in
your mind and get real quiet thing that
got me through is everything got quiet
everything became Charlie Brown all
those teachers all those parents all
those people tell me I couldn't I wasn't
where I was losing I just drowned them
out and so that would be my
recommendation drown out the noise and
get real focused on the opportunity
because I have a lot of empathy that you
may not see it right now but it doesn't
mean it's not there and I see it every
day I get emails and DMS every day the
people that are building up from real
small places it's just patience I
believe you if anything it's patience
patience how many people in this room
right now over 30 raise your hands they
don't know right when you were 14 you
felt bold like a girl but like you don't
get it how early it is I'm 42 years old
I feel exactly the same way I did when I
was 16 I got straight fire in my chest
I'm hungry I want it feels the same I
don't even know what to tell you and all
the denied people that just raised your
hand will tell you the same thing we're
still thinking about the same dumb [ __ ]
we did when we were 15 we're still
ambitious we still want it was still
growing it's the same thing and you
can't see that now and neither could i
when I wanted to the liquor store when I
was 22 years old my cousin was
thirty I thought he was old me now so I
know what you think
I get it I remember I've got a good
enough memory but I'm not trying to rob
you or give you hope off some [ __ ]
I'm just trying to tell you the truth
which is the internet's here it's a
complete land grab there's an unlimited
opportunity nobody cares where you
started nobody's stopping you there's
nobody that's got to take your resume
there's no grades that matter none of it
what matters is are you willing to
hustle and how bad do you want it and
are you willing to live a life where
you're not letting other people judge
you so then you're not pandering to it
the biggest problem I see right now with
a lot of people that a lot of twenty
thirty year old guys follow me and every
one of them
it's just buying dumb [ __ ] like just
buying dumb [ __ ] like clothes and
watches and sneakers all because they're
trying to front and use it to get girls
and all that that's fine I get it but
they're letting other people dictate
their life and that is the biggest thing
that if you could get out of this talk
if you can get nobody to dictate your
life and I'm talking this organization
your parents your friends nobody if you
can get into that crazy place that I got
to and the other people that I study and
watch that broke through it's got to get
real quiet and that's what I'm hoping
for you so that's where I'm at my first
question if you don't have social media
and you only have access to Internet at
school how do you use the internet to be
resourceful and even get a job well
first of all you have to decide if you
want to get a job and second of all like
if you're going into your computer lab
right you know you could sign into your
Instagram for that minute 15 minutes for
hours you know here's what I would do
for everybody here I would do everything
possible I would do and I mean
everything possible like and and I just
you have to understand I you know I
lived the version of this life not to
the extremity that you did but I to me
the big game is very simp
if I know one person if I know one
person that did it then there's a
blueprint and so you know obviously it
was coming here and I did a little
searching one guy's like yo I was
homeless I got $10 from handouts I
caught your video cuz the other phone my
service was cut off a month later so I
lost you I didn't have it but I had that
ten bucks I heard you I went and bought
ten dollars worth of water at the bodega
went outside sold it May 2010 building
and he remembered he remembered that
they the the thrift store a thrift store
flip he walked in he had 47 dollars he
bought a pair of Jordans go in a thrift
store for 19 he sold him for 57 on ebay
he just kept going and going and going
and going and going and going
he didn't care what people were saying
when he sold water outside he didn't
care what people said when he was going
into every thrift store he didn't give a
[ __ ] he just kept going and going and
going
saved up enough to turn back on his
service get a year's worth of service
now he's back on the internet now he's
really flipping stuff on the Instagram
in Amazon and eBay and there he just
kept on and he made thousands of
thousands of dollars then he got in a
part of like my big thing is what's your
alternative like what are you gonna sin
[ __ ] dwell so it's just there yeah
you just have it so much better than
people that looked like you and had your
situation 30 40 years ago and didn't
have the web period period so I don't
know it's just remarkable it's just
remarkable I don't know what to say that
wasn't real that wasn't real when I was
a kid I was buying all sorts of dumb
[ __ ] to sell but I had to go to flea
markets on the weekend fine eBay [ __ ] I
don't know Jets now
all right you guys have questions people
got questions they're just worried about
people's judgement on that question
I want to answer one on one basic [ __ ]
I'll answer anything thank you
what's your name Kayla how are you good
yep yep
you know being a writer singer dancer
and getting to that goal uses a sick
look I think the Internet is the magic
pill right so like if you again if you
can get to the place where you have
social you need to write sing and dance
on Instagram use hashtags right you got
the [ __ ] book you can read it you can
go sell it for 4 bucks I don't give a
[ __ ] what you do but you need to go out
and you have to make content at scale
because if you can sing you need
exposure so if you can sing well then
that my question is this is not just you
know like I think people get confused by
making it if you want to write sing and
dance you also have to figure out how
that's balanced with how you're gonna
live right so there's a big difference
between being Beyonce and being somebody
makes 50,000 a year or singing both are
interesting that's your talent so first
of all you gotta figure out how good you
are because people are delirious out
here people think they're going to the
league
people think they're gonna they're the
next meek you know people think that
they're [ __ ] the next Beyonce like
people are delirious out here meanwhile
some people are a so to me here's the
funniest part there's no more debating
take your phone
point at your fit self and do it and
then figure out if people like it and
when people say they don't like it you
got to make more of it you need two
three four years of rejection before you
give up years people post one post on
Instagram of them freestyling people
[ __ ] on them and they give up
make content got it
you want to write right if it's good
it's gonna be fallout go ahead yes you
were the lower spectrum of straight A's
what [ __ ] did you go got yep yeah okay
yep yep yep yep yep look nice me
swooping in for an hour taking a couple
selfies signing a book for you it's not
gonna get it done right this is way
beyond this moment so I'm not delirious
about this here's what you and I were
able to do we were able to hear a lot of
things and block it out any people have
questions but they're scared to ask
because they're scared of the judgement
of the questions of the person sitting
next to them so I get it like I I have
plenty versions of that too like
everybody's got it like I can do this
but there's other things I wouldn't do
because I'm scared of the judgment I'm
not gonna dance in front of you because
it's gonna be wack as [ __ ] I wanna be
left like I get it right I get it but
here's the punchline there is no
alternative
right so for me you know I'm not I'm not
ideological I don't think I'm rollin in
here and gonna inspire everybody to go
get there like to me it's just putting
facts in people's heads and moving on
this is what it is like for example
you're gonna get pushed education like
crazy let me tell you what's going on
with education unless you're a really
good student and you think you're gonna
go to a top university that's gonna give
you a scholarship and you're gonna get a
great job by the time you guys get to
the college system it's not gonna be
that great of a deal for you and if you
are thinking
about going to college and collecting
debt at 11% you're gonna really be in
bad shape until you're 40
that's facts that's not popular your mom
and teachers don't want to tell you that
I get it
but that's [ __ ] facts College is
broken in America now when you're 13 16
9
that sounds great like yeah [ __ ] school
I get it but for some of you schools
exactly right because you've got it like
that you understand it you figured out
the system you know how to get good
grades and maybe you should go
especially if people gonna pay for it
and you don't get that right so what I'm
just saying is that everybody's gonna
have a different path
everybody's gonna different paths you
just need to figure out what you like
and what you're good at and if you're
lucky enough that what you like is what
you're good at well then you [ __ ] won
but if not you got to decide if you're
gonna live a life where you're gonna do
something that makes you happy and you
like it and maybe you're not gonna have
private jets and all that stuff or
you're gonna live a life where you're
just gonna make some money cuz you want
to get that place out and that that's
what you want this is about choices
there is no perfect you already know
that that is your advantage yes sir yeah
Boehner yes it was busy the pivot yes
yes yes
they want to see themselves what do you
have in terms of advice one look and you
know this like the vision at this age is
far more fancy you know you get less
fancy with your vision as you get older
right when you're 12 you're gonna play
in the league you're gonna be a famous
this you're gonna be an influencer
you're gonna be a famous vlogger you're
gonna win Grammys like and then as you
get there 18 and that you know how that
works so for me you know if this was
college kids the pivots super
interesting cuz they've been hit with
that cold water like oh [ __ ] I don't
want to be a doctor
I want to make money or whatever it was
right that made you switch it up you
know for me right now it's like I'm just
you know it's funny what's running
through my head right now I'm like man
is there one kid in here that hears me
right I'm like is there one [ __ ] kid
that understands like stop crying stop
crying like nobody's listening there's
people that have compassion I got
compassion for days the problem is I
know there's four billion people that
have it worse than you I don't know it's
to say so like I got some compassion for
you so you know like you know what I
think we're all it's trying to achieve
here because we have compassion we care
I'm just trying to come at it not from a
different angle I'm not trying to shock
you with my cursing that's just what
happens when I have people in front of
me I'm just trying to get somebody to
believe and not like hyped and then not
care next Tuesday I'm just trying to
make sure one thing resonates in
somebody's you know how it works we all
lived it right like just one piece of
thing that could resonate and the only
thing that ever resonates you know I
yeah I'm very you know I'm just very
affected by growing up in New Jersey and
just like East Coast and like the 80s
when the Beastie Boys about you know and
I just when I think back to like culture
right now what resonates is only one of
two things
complete and utter [ __ ] and straight
[ __ ] truth right either like stuff
that just everybody dreams of like oh
[ __ ] yes 50 [ __ ] bottles of
and private jets and [ __ ] flossin
coast-to-coast you know or just the
truth I'm not interested in selling that
because it's not practical for 99.99% I
like talking in this environment but the
truth and the truth is not what these
kids get a lot they get ideology they
get people that come up here and spit
facts that make them feel good that they
checked the box and spent an hour I'm
not interested in that
I'm interested in getting somebody to do
something and the only way to do that is
to suffocate the [ __ ] that's running
through their head what's your name
again
Joe they don't love it
I'm a fan of it if it gets you out of a
situation that you're not interested in
if we're being direct here like if that
can get you to the next spot
I'm interested I worked for my dad's
liquor store when I was from 22 to 34
years old
I filled my dad's liquor store to a 60
million dollar business and at 34 years
old I left and had nothing it was my
dad's business I would inherit it one
day but I hope my dad lives forever and
I'll be 90 right so like I did what I
thought was right different circumstance
but I did what I thought I was right I
was an immigrant kid my parents took me
from shitty Russia to America I wanted
to pay them back I worked my face off
gave up all my twenties right so we're
easy to be humble with her when you're
humble you know so you know when I hear
you asking that question without knowing
every one of your details I think you
got to do what you have to do to get to
the next step to give yourself more
options got it so like if you're good at
it and it works and they can get you to
that next spot that gives you options at
30 held are you Mazal they're 15 if that
can get you to a place of 27 that gives
you options you'll be a kid at 27 at 15
you think 27 [ __ ] dead old I get it I
remember but I'm telling you to your
face
it's young kid you're a young kid how
many people here would love to be 27 get
to that next spot I get it listen let me
tell you one thing that you will not
hear often the person that knows how to
eat the most amount of [ __ ] usually eats
the most amount of caviar got it you
need to eat [ __ ] get to the next spot
not directly but you understand if it's
good like that you're not gonna get you
to the next spot that's perfect
regardless of what it is whatever gets
you to the next spot is exactly move
forward it's good man
I'm glad you if you have something like
that brewing that excites me that's real
easy for me to see how it can go for you
you just got to be patient
that's where you got to stay disciplined
and save that money and not buy all the
stuff that's getting fed to you that you
need it's hard to get the next spot when
you spend seven hundred bucks to buy a
supreme bag
well I definitely want this man and I
got I wanted to be a little late my man
right here who I've been paying
attention to the whole time
what's your name nice to meet you
I liked it
I had a meeting today with a sports
agent my brother and the AJ and I
started a sports agency right so we now
represent players in in football and is
a big shot and he's like he was like in
one of those conferences with me and I
was educating on what we're doing and he
kind of took a step back he's like oh
whoa this is this is way bigger than I
thought like you guys are really gonna
win this thing huh and I said yeah and I
said to him and this is my favorite part
when all the agents that think they're
big shots with big players are [ __ ]
on me and making fun of us why not when
people were putting me down man I was
collecting them in my head I just don't
believe in anybody's opinion about me
more than I believe and they pin their
God about myself
do you know what the most delicious
flavor in the world is I told you so you
understand I don't I don't I don't
admire anybody enough to take their
point of view on me over my own listen
let me tell you something about this
country we love the rags to riches story
a hell of a lot more than any other
story you are set up for the good [ __ ]
it's just are you gonna work hard enough
and get into the right mental place to
get there well what do you define as bad
inspiration like what who do you think
is a bad role model okay well like the
way I look at anything is if I decided
it's a bad role model it's not a role
model you know you know I mean if you're
saying that it's a bad role model
because other people say it but you like
it or think some of the parts of what
they're doing or good that's what you
have to dissect nobody's all good
nobody's all bad to me it's just picking
the pieces that you're interested in my
guy how are you
I consider your like a real yeah yeah I
feel worse for that man yeah like like
it's really hard to walk into this room
look at their faces and have what's
going through my head as these kids have
such a big advantage they have no idea
because they could never believe it and
nobody out there would think it they I'd
be judged as a bad guy to think every
kid in here has it better than all the
rich kids on the Upper West Side I just
believe it because it's my truth it
sucks man think about what you just said
you know which it's like that was how
Wyatt brought up that other kid like
you're like JFK like that means that
person lost from the get what you're
basically saying is if you're born with
money you've lost from day one so like
and honestly I'm not so sold that you're
not wrong like I do pee but we also are
judging the game when you don't have
anything you want stuff so you don't
give a [ __ ] about merit or respect or
skills you're just trying to get some
stuff but once you get it how you get it
becomes the game and so some of us are
fortunate to be judging people on the
skills not the stuff so for me once I
you know once I made $100,000 a year
Antonio then I was good but I thought
I'd made it forever I've never felt the
impact of money since that mark the same
way cuz I don't need stuff like like I
don't need stuff the reason I love being
an entrepreneur is because nobody's my
[ __ ] boss
so like making 80,000 a year selling
rubber bands on Amazon sounds great to
me because nobody's yelling at me how
many rubber like I just like the
autonomy I like the control you know I'm
a nice guy it's leverage when you're
giving more than you're asking for
you've got the leverage I like leverage
hold on know what good advice would be
like if you fail at something what keeps
you and what do you think are some of
the good things that might help some
people well for me the reason I always
do things that I think I might fail at
is because I don't care what anybody
thinks if I lose it's a very big deal
guys the reason I take so many risks and
always did and that's why I won was
because if I lost I didn't care about
what anybody thought about my L it's my
[ __ ] L I'm telling you if you can
figure out how to get every voice out of
your mind your whole life will change
doesn't mean you know take advice from
people but if you realize how to get
quiet up here everything is different
man what's scary about failure
I love losing means I learned something
figures figured out how not to do it
again right
they say well I say to is like the only
way that you can learn this from your
mistakes and I made you learn from
winning too but let me tell you one
thing
not trying they're doing always loses
you'll learn from winning I've learned a
ton of [ __ ] from winning I've learned a
lot from losing the only thing I've done
much better than a lot of people is I'm
always doing well you're sitting and
debating should I or could i or how or
what I'm working go ahead my man that's
a great that's a great question my man
so I got real lucky even though there
wasn't a lot and I was coming up a
certain way my mom did it for me
nah now my grandma did not do it for my
dad right she was an old Eastern
European woman she did it different I'm
gonna give you an extremely extremely
this is what I'm so glad that I let a
little more questions go because you
just asked a real important question
something I really hope people can
understand it's gonna be really real
please pay attention to this one thing
the only way I've seen now that I'm
older that you can build confidence is
if you surround yourself with people
that are optimistic it's just super real
it's super hard what I'm about to say to
you everybody in this room needs to cut
out as much of the noise and time with
people that are negative and spend as
much time with people that are positive
and I'm not talking about positive as
like there's people in the toughest
situations that are optimistic and
positive and there's the people that
have the most in the world that are
pessimistic and negative this isn't
where you're at or what you got this is
are the people that you're sitting with
at school
on the bus the shelter is here right now
are they saying how shitty everything is
or they talk about how to get the [ __ ]
out
get rid of everybody who says it's
shitty including family members I'm not
kidding
doesn't mean run away from home like you
know but kinda there's only one way to
build confidence my guy it's having
people that are reinforcing good things
to you
it's brainwashing [ __ ] for real yes how
are you what's your name
Lee say how you doing good riding on
ycteen and I spilled my heart I was just
me yes yes like it's like they yeah get
it it's like that's me yes they not
accepting me [ __ ] them nobody honestly
guys first of all they didn't decline
you one random [ __ ] person that read
your [ __ ] declined you [ __ ] them you're
wrong you're wrong listen in my face I'm
telling you right to your face you're
wrong you're valuing somebody else's
opinion too much you're wrong I I'm just
telling this is not this is not a debate
you're [ __ ] wrong do you understand
you're letting one random person listen
you do you understand how many people
would have hired me none who's got
Instagram in here cool go to it right
now please do me a huge [ __ ] favor go
to Instagram go to Gary Vee that's my
account go ten eleven posts back you'll
see my report card I was ranked 243rd
out of 254 in my class 243 at a 254 in
my class you know why because I knew it
was [ __ ] for me it might not people
[ __ ] for you this is about self
awareness you have to know who the [ __ ]
you are but for me
it was [ __ ] cuz I didn't need it
because I wasn't tricked I didn't give a
[ __ ] with Saturn how many rings Saturn
had listen to me you can't let something
be valuable more that you could you're
pandering to them let them come to you
take that same essay and post that [ __ ]
on Instagram with a photo and see what
happens
see what happens let the market decide
not some [ __ ] middle management
person that read your [ __ ] good of
course it's true
and when you're young in 13 and 15 and 9
you think you got to change your [ __ ] up
because you don't know how it's played
that's why I'm here to tell you exactly
how it's played one [ __ ] person read
your story my dear and [ __ ] that person
[Applause]
who else has got a question not yet
Nicole anybody else good what's that one
more time I apologize yes yes you know
that's a really tough question to answer
obviously mindset came natural to me it
was a circumstantial thing here's what I
was say back to the same way this was
not a debate my friends if you're
thinking positively good things are
gonna happen if you're thinking
negatively bad things are gonna happen I
really it's just it's so weird right
because when the cool says I'm a
motivational that's like I don't want to
be a mode of it I don't want to be I
mean it I was 34 years old I was a
businessman there was no motivational me
there was no writing books there was no
person now there's no 3.2 million
followers on Instagram I was practical I
worked and I thought life was good even
though I didn't have you know I felt
life was good when I didn't have [ __ ]
like I get worried that Aunt
Oh thinks I think life is good cuz I
have money in the bank [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like like my my grandkids are gonna get
like like I'm not gonna spend it you're
not gonna spend it it's the same [ __ ] so
like it's just to me well it just became
obvious to me that it wasn't a good idea
to listen to other people like what
right like the thought that like you
know how happy I am right now that I
stayed here and we had that conversation
it's one person like I think your
tie-dyed hoodie is [ __ ] rad dude
behind you might think it's [ __ ] you
know it's just the way it is people's
got opinions like it's just one person
it's not that's not the coal company so
I'm not sure you know what what I would
tell you is I just choose optimism just
because I know if I choose pessimism
it's over if I choose that Donald
Trump's gonna ruin America I'll be sad
if I choose that it doesn't mean [ __ ]
like I'd be the same way I felt about
Barack Obama and Bush and every other
president if you think the president is
dictating your life you're a [ __ ]
loser but no alternative like what
nobody's gonna cry for me like like you
think about this situation for people in
here right I can be empathetic I
understand what you're gonna put down on
you know how I got here why it doesn't
it doesn't just happen there's some
other nasty [ __ ] that gets to this
moment here's my problem the post at the
doctor's office today this is just real
person walks out crying terminally ill
finished dead thirty days I feel worse
for that person I don't care you have
had the same pair of clothes your whole
life least you're allowed to go to that
back you got a shot
I choose optimism
please good yeah
what's your name I didn't catch you last
time saying cool good it's all the same
themes man I just don't care what you
got like I walk it like in here or when
I speak to 7,000 people Madison Square
Garden the other day like I just don't
care
fear comes from willing to let somebody
else have the other upper hand on
judgment I'm gonna give my best I came
here and gave you my best I'm 30 rocks
already bent out of shape because he
knows I'm 30 minutes late for this
important meeting but like I'm giving my
best right here cuz this is more
important to me but like if everybody
leaves here and says that crazy white
dude [ __ ] him right I don't care cuz I
know I just left it on the line so I'm
always gonna do me and if it works out
good and if it doesn't good
[Music]